you
[Music]
I'm gonna try to keep this short because
I don't think she needs much
introduction but it is my great pleasure
to introduce professor Anna Gilbert
she is a the Herman H Goldstein
professor mathematics at the Department
of Professor mathematics at the
University of Michigan joint appointment
of ECE she's you know one of the really
one of the Giants of her field uh she's
won a number of awards and she's done
really some of the pioneering work in
algorithms for compressed sensing
functional analysis of harmonica
analysis signal processing and today
she's gonna be talking to us about some
of her recent work on sparse symmetric
repair so please join me in welcoming
professor Gilbert thank you thank you
it is uh it is a real pleasure to be
here this is my first time coming to
Microsoft research and and it's just
great to be here
so I thought that in discussing the
geometry of deep learning rather than
focusing on algorithms per se I should
talk about the geometry of data and the
input to all of these algorithms and so
I'm going to talk about three papers
that are joint in various subsets with
violet Jane who moved from Michigan to
University of Washington so he's local
and Rishi Santoya who is my student at
the University Shenyang
and then this cast of characters whom I
have actually never met in person so
there are a lot of fun to work with and
hopefully I'll get to meet them in
person one day ok so I'm going to talk
about the geometry of data and in
particular repairing your data so that
they adhere to a proper metric so that
they are no longer distorted and
hopefully are a closer approximation to
reality than something that looks like
this so too you know we're going to go
from distorted geometry to hopefully
correct a geometry again
at this point I'm gonna make my standard
joke about English and about
mathematicians mathematicians always
like to say fix X bla bla bla and I'm
going to use the word repair instead of
fix okay yeah okay got it
so so what is it what is the motivation
so um
typically in just about any kind of
machine learning type algorithm were
given data and maybe its similarity
matrix but you know whatever it is it's
a set of distances or we calculate a set
of distances in some way and these
distances are supposed to be from a
metric they're supposed to adhere to a
metric and in particular when your data
are from a metric then you can run
downstream unsupervised machine learning
algorithms quite successfully like
clustering in more traditional computer
science world there are approximation
algorithms which will give you better
guarantees if your distances adhere to a
metric much better than if they don't
and then of course there are all kinds
of applications in computer vision and
in computational biology which get
better when your data adhere to a metric
okay so that seems to beg the question
how do we ensure that the distances that
we're given or the similarity data that
we're given how do we ensure that it had
here's to a metric it seems like a
reasonable question okay so what do I
mean by adhere to a metric so this is a
crash course and basic analysis so I'm
going to assume that my matrix D is my
set of distances my matrix my matrix of
distances and it is distances amongst
endpoint
it is a symmetric matrix the entries are
non-negative and the distance from any
point to itself should be 0 and the
distances should satisfy a triangle
inequality the triangle inequality so
this is the statement that the distances
adhere to a triangle inequality okay
right not check my past undergraduate
analysis no yeah okay fine yeah and
that's actually not such the problem
okay
so um I can rewrite this system of
triangle inequalities as a large matrix
times the vector eyes to form of my
distance matrix just vectorize it and
then saying that my distances adhere to
a metric means that this matrix times
the vector eyes form of this matrix are
entry wise greater than or equal to zero
and then what does this matrix m look
like each row of M corresponds to a
triangle
IJ K and the triangle inequality matrix
is structured there are three nonzero
entries in each row two of them are ones
and one of them is minus one okay so I
want M times the vectorized form of D to
be entry wise greater than or equal to
zero okay and so formally what do I mean
by metric repair I mean given some
corrupted metric D Prime ie some
triangle inequality is broken then I
would like to find a perturbation that
repairs not that fixes but that repairs
the the corrupted input and in
particular I want M times the perturbed
input to be entry wise greater than
equal to zero okay it makes complete
sense okay all right here do use the
corrupt
P is the repair sorry D prime is the
corruption D is the correction is the
correct mmm is a correct version P is
the repair okay and there are many
techniques for solving this problem may
be somewhat disguised but there are a
number of traditional techniques so sort
of most obviously closely related is a
paper by brick l at all from about 2007
that solves this problem by projecting
the corrupt data onto the subspace of
metrics onto the cone of metrics and
that projection essentially minimizes
the l2 norm or the Frobenius distance
between your correct you're correct your
corrected data and then your corrupted
input okay and that is the perturbation
and they give various algorithms for
doing this more more specifically
instead of just correcting or repairing
to any old metric one could ask to
repair or project onto the cone of
Euclidean distance matrices maybe you
feel very strongly that your distances
should be Euclidean and this is
otherwise known as multi-dimensional
scaling and it has extensive
applications and development in the
psychometric literature and this is
essentially the mathematical statement
of what it means to repair your data to
a Euclidean distance matrix in sort of
to repair give me the closest in
Frobenius norm the closest to repair you
could also go back and do a little
revisionist history there is a lovely
paper from the late 90s by Berger at all
that gives a randomized algorithm for
metric repair in r3 even more
revisionist history you
view some of the rigidity theory that KO
she was working on in the 1800s as a way
of asking about missing Euclidean
distances and whether or not polygons
remain polygons when you shake them and
move them around so the problem with all
of these methods is that they perturb
most of the distances even ones that are
correct
so to speak so we want a more optimistic
approach and we want to assume that most
of the distances are correct and they're
only a few of them are actually
corrupted and we would like to make as
few changes as few repairs as possible
maintaining the original correct
we hope structure of the data okay so
well what does that mean we would like
to make as few changes as possible so
that means we should minimize the l0
pseudo norm of the perturbation P
subject to the perturbation corrects
things this seems like a natural setup
okay great we have a math problem
alas it's non convex one might be
tempted so just make sense this is the
sparsa symmetric repair okay one might
be tempted to replace that content non
convex objective function with a convex
one please do not be so tempted because
it doesn't work very well at least not
in the naive way so the naive convex
relaxation doesn't give the sparsa
solutions in in general and you know
it's just kind of not really the right
set up of the problem you can fix it so
to speak you can repair this algorithm
and come up with at least something in
practice that's more sophisticated than
this naive l1 minimization but it's kind
of the wrong approach to the problem I
think okay so it's the wrong approach to
the problem for
bunch of reasons you might be tempted to
think that it's the wrong approach
because convex optimization mmm is will
lead to a lot of constraints possibly
something like n cubed constraints that
come from each triangle inequality and
this might be computationally expensive
mmm we might want to have rigorous
guarantees about our algorithm more
importantly we might want to explore
exploit the combinatorial nature of this
problem there's a graph here they're
triangles I can count them so a
seemingly easier question is given a
data set um and given a matrix of
distances can we even efficiently detect
whether the input is even a metric could
we find in the broken triangles quickly
maybe as a subroutine um alas no
probably not
so n cubed is probably where we're stuck
at for this problem
so Williams and Williams showed a lovely
sub cubic barrier so the following
weighted problems either all have truly
sub cubic algorithms or none of them do
okay look second on the list is checking
whether or not a matrix and whether or
not a given matrix defines a metric okay
so I'm willing to punt on n cubed
algorithms I'm not willing to punt on
convex relaxation in particular I'm
paying attention to the first problem in
this list and that is that is naturally
a a graph problem the old parish
naturally also a combinatorial problem
they all pair shortest path problem so
somehow shortest path is somehow related
to whether or not a matrix defines a
metric so let me use that as inspiration
for diving more deeply into this problem
of metric repair and so in particular I
probably can't do better than a cubic
algorithm okay fine let's go explore
some combinatoric s-- okay so i'm going
to break down my metric repair problem
into a couple of different cases
not-not-not every case seems like it
should be equally problematic or said
another way given a broken triangle it
seems like there should be a lot of
different ways I could repair it
I'm trying to explain I'm trying to
motivate to you there are three
different kinds of problems okay so I
have a broken triangle one two and seven
it's broken okay
and I want to repair it in such a way
that my repairs consist of decreases in
the original distances decreases only I
cannot increase things
okay so I've bowed out seven to make it
look like that's the leg of the triangle
you should change and you should
decrease it so I should decrease it to
three okay this makes sense okay then
the next case is maybe I take the point
of view or I take the constraint that
its leg one that is too short for one
two and seven and I'm going to constrain
myself to perturbations that only
increase the length of some leg of a
broken triangle so I increase one to
five and then my triangle is repaired
okay and then I could do then I'm going
to observe that the solution that I get
in this case is not at all related to
the solution that I get in this case and
in particular a sparse decrease only
metric repair solution might not give a
sparse increase only metric repair
solution you know imagine imagine more
than one triangle so I have lots lots of
triangles around both cases you have a
unique solution that algorithm will
converge to if you just decrease so it
is true in this case um I'm gonna tell
you exactly what it is in a second in
this case no well iterative how long
does it take for the thing to convert
you should ask me is is really the
question okay so in this case I'm gonna
tell you everything okay so I'm gonna
consider these two cases separately and
then of course there's the general the
general situation where we don't place
any restrictions on the perturbation we
can increase some we can decrease others
completely general so I can go check and
change one and seven to four and five
for example okay um and I'm gonna look
only at the decrease only metric repair
problem for right now because I'm going
to dispense with it fairly quickly I'm
gonna dispense with it fairly quickly by
telling you you should run the
floyd-warshall algorithm on the complete
graph and you're done so in particular
if you go look at the floyd-warshall
algorithm it says if this triangle is
broken then decrease the length of that
edge decrease it to the shortest path
okay so when Lalla and i were working on
this and we spent embarrassingly too
long thinking about this problem and he
came in one day and he said anna you
know i was a CS major I learned this
isn't my undergraduate algorithms class
oh that's good I'm glad you took it and
yeah but what's embarrassing is that
brick L at all didn't notice this either
so anyway floyd-warshall
all pair shortest path algorithm is a an
N cubed time algorithm for decrease only
metric repair and if you set D prime D
hat to be the all pair shortest path
solution for the complete graph with
edge weights given by D prime then the
perturbation is simply the difference
between the two the two matrices and it
is the correct thing to do
intuitively speaking to fix a triangle
what you should do is you should
decrease this distance that's too big to
be the shortest path between these two
vertices and so actually broke a little
actually noticed that part of this
problem was related to the solution that
you would get from running the
floyd-warshall algorithm so what they
noted was that your corrected or any
solution to the decrease only version
was element wise smaller than the
solution that you got from
floyd-warshall and then what Lola and I
showed was that this perturbation is in
fact actually the sparse aspossible
decrease only metric repair solution so
it is the sparse cysts and in particular
it is also the one that has minimal LP
minimal LP distance to the input so for
any for any any norm P so not only is it
the sparse list but it's also the
closest in L 1 norm it's not just yeah
just LP yeah so for P equals 0 or
pronate yeah yeah it's this partial as
possible Oh
fully decrease only yeah yeah great for
further for decrease only ok so check
this problem is done an undergraduate
algorithms undergraduate algorithm will
solve this we're we're good ok
that suggests that we should turn our
attention to the increase only case and
the in the general case and I have bad
news for you there is it decreasing or I
see when you do yeah yeah sorry I can't
check this in real time but yeah okay so
right I write these are entry wise
smaller than that so I've decreased
everything okay good test of eyesight
and brain okay so I I have I have erased
from the board the decrease only problem
that solved everything is great let's
turn our attention to the increase only
case and what could possibly go wrong
what kinds of problems might we have
well the problem that we might have is
that if we have a broken triangle so I J
is greater than I cape Loess JK we can't
figure out which a priori we can't
figure out which leg it is of this
triangle that we should increase that we
should make longer so you know either
this one is the right one or this one is
the right one and whatever choice you
make may have some detrimental impact on
the triangles that you want to repair
sort of later on downstream and they
algorithm okay so also if you go if you
do just sort of a simple thought
experiment and try and solve this
problem by minimizing the l1 norm of the
perturbation there are lots of possible
solutions but few of them are sparse so
in particular you know I can do all
kinds of changes to my triangles to my
triangle and keep the total l1 norm
equal to
or lots and lots of different exes okay
so convex optimization is not a good
approach even for this particular
problem
I still want I want some kind of
combinatorial approach and and it's a
hard problem okay so I'm now going to
tell you about extensions and
generalizations of this problem so that
you can see some of the increase only
metric repair solutions so you can see
ah you know the these are the results
that are available you know it makes it
makes sense to talk about them in the
context of a general graph rather than a
complete graph I'm then going to tell
you about using these algorithms to
repair manifolds or at least repair the
distances that you calculate on a data
set which you assume or hypothesize lies
on some low dimensional manifold so we
want to correct the distances so that
one can do good low dimensional
embedding and then what Rishi and I are
currently working on is a bunch of
algorithms for four different kinds of
metric learning using using these
techniques okay so the first
generalization and extension that I'm
going to talk about which is the graph
metric repair and it's a setting for
which the it's a setting which is
natural to discuss the increase only
case okay so this is I'm going to
generalize from the complete graph to a
general graph and from broken triangles
to broken cycles okay so the idea why
would you want to do this the idea is
that you might want to impose some kind
of relations amongst your data points
like this data
point is not at all related to that data
point and so I should not care about
Ivan fact I should ignore the distances
the distance between these two data
points you might want to say for example
this data point is in a different
cluster from that data point you might
want to say hey all of these data points
are somehow related to one another and
so I should have I should have edges in
some graph amongst all these guys and
not amongst all of these guys except for
maybe one or two so this is a
generalization of the complete graph
where I have all of the distances
amongst all of the pairs of points and
hopefully you can see somehow morally
speaking this is a broken cycle because
this edge is heavy it's too long okay
all right so formally speaking what is
the graph metric repair problem so I'm
given a weighted undirected graph G and
some set of allowed perturbation values
so a subset of R that I'm going to use
to adjust the weights on my graph okay
and I want to find the smallest set of
edges such that by modifying the weight
of each edge in that subset s by adding
some value from Omega so it could be
positive it could be negative it could
be both the new distances on the graph
satisfy a metric so all the cycles have
are not broken they're not too heavy
they're not too light so this problem is
we called a graph metric repair it's
related to matrix completion to graph
cutting problems to metric nearness
which is the problem from the Buerkle
paper and related to metric embeddings
was outliers but this is the formal
statement of the problem that we're
interested in and using this machinery
we're able to come up with a number of
results for the decrease only case and
then to study more thoroughly the
increase only in the general cases so
you know as we discussed on the complete
graph the decrease only problem has a
lovely polynomial time solution a cubic
time solution this is also true on the
graph and then we have a result that
says that if you are if you permit even
just one one single number in one single
positive number by which you might
potentially increase the distances in
your graph then the problem becomes
np-complete so it's a radical change
from decreasing Li to increase only so
then for the increase only case we have
some approximation preserving reductions
from these graph cut problems
we also have several we have several
different approximation algorithms they
come in a couple different flavors
they're both the two that are in the
paper
ar-ar-ar each parameterised by different
measures of how far the input is from a
metric so it's the length of the one of
the algorithms is the length of the
longest broken cycle and I think the
other one is the heaviest weight we're
lightest weight I forget of the broken
cycle we also have a number of we have a
number of heuristics so Lalla and I did
a whole slew of experiments and came up
with some heuristic algorithms they work
well in practice on the kinds of random
graphs that and random data sets that we
created we can also show
at least for one of them that the worst
case approximation guarantee is like o
of n so they're there they're great and
practice and terrible and theory anyway
uh the main result that I want to at
least tell you tad bit more in detail
about is we have a fixed parameter
tractable algorithm for for the graph
for a graph when it's this is a Sigma
when Sigma is quartel and you know for
any fixed constant Sigma there is an FPT
and so I'm just going to give you a few
of the key ideas in this in this
algorithm or in showing that there is
such an algorithm and in showing you
that there's a verifier for a potential
solution to this problem and and it goes
back to the shortest path again so if
the shortest path between two adjacent
vertices in your graph is not to the
edge connecting them and something is
wrong with this edge and in particular
it's the heavy edge of a broken cycle
okay so remember the picture of the
cycle where all of the edges are one
except one is ten and it's bowed out
tremendously okay so that ten is more
than the sum of these little lengths
here so something is wrong with that
particular edge okay and so there's a
structural theorem that says again I'm
gonna tell you this is all for the
increase only case for any positively
weighted graph and a subset of edges II
the subset of edges s s is a set of
edges that is at what we call a regular
cover ie it contains at least one edge
from each broken cycle if and only if F
is the support to a solution to this is
the general the general increase the
general metric repair problem okay and
then so that's one idea
it's a
is know if you write it gives you a
characterization of the solutions to the
problem
next we have an algorithm that is a
verifier so suppose you have a potential
set of edges s that might be a potential
support for the solution then in n cubed
time you can determine whether or not
there is a valid solution on that
support s and if if it exists then it
finds it and you know it is essentially
reconfigure the weights in the graph
that are not in sorry for edges that are
in in the potential set set them equal
to some large value for edges that are
not in that potential set keep them the
same and then run a shortest path
algorithm in the new graph and if the
weights changed then then return the how
they were changed otherwise it's false
okay so we have a result that says I'm
sorry we have a theorem that proves that
this verifier does what it's supposed to
do and then then we can use that to cook
up an FPT algorithm which I will not
give you the full detail of but I just
want to tell you it exists and this is
the running time
oops yeah okay sorry that is that is
correct you know whether or not this is
practical I don't know how this compares
to our heuristic approximation
algorithms I also don't know you know
this is what this is what we can prove
what we can and it's quite far from it's
quite far from what we used
I can tell you this and for the next for
the next setting okay so I'm not gonna
go into into details as kind of
technical okay so what I will talk about
next is an application of these ideas to
repairing your data that ostensibly you
think lie on a low dimensional manifold
okay so a whether or not one believes
this I will leave up to you but a
typical model of real-world data is that
it lies on a low dimensional manifold
embedded in a high dimensional space and
there are all these fantastic dimension
reduction algorithms that try to unroll
so to speak or embed this manifold in
low dimensional space I have a friend
who Swiss and she tells me that there is
no such thing as a Swiss roll in
Switzerland
she says it's called something else okay
so how do these how do these dimension
reductions how do they actually work so
what is what are their various building
their building blocks well first of all
they begin with some data and then they
compute a distance matrix or perhaps you
were given a similarity matrix a
distance matrix and then you build a
graph on those data points using your
distance matrix as the edge weights of
the graph maybe you adjust this a little
bit it's the Jew doesn't whatever fine
their distances and then you look at
maybe the K neighborhood of any given
point or you build a graph looking at
just epsilon neighborhood of any point
you connect you connect data points with
edges if they all if those all those
data points lie within some epsilon
neighborhood of the other point what
whatever you do you're building a graph
and you're using
distance information to build this graph
and then the algorithms like these
manifold learning algorithms like ISO
map or lle they take this information to
generate a low dimensional
representation of the data and that's
all fine and good but what happens if
you have a problem right here or a
problem right here so many of these
dimension reduction algorithms have
theoretical guarantees along the lines
of if you add some noise to your data
some noise how much and what it looks
like compared to the manifold then you
know then the dimension reduction
algorithm works relatively well but I'm
not a big fan of additive white Gaussian
noise as a model for how my data get
corrupted in particular many actual data
sets have missing entries so you know
you can't get if you have survey
responses you can't get people to answer
surveys if you are looking at rating
systems you can't get people to rate
every possible thing you might be
interested in if you ask people to rank
various items it's much easier to ask
them to rank two items at a time as
opposed to all n of them I work a lot
with computational biologists and I work
on single-cell RNA sequencing data and
many of those many of those data sets
have entries they generate matrices
where we do not know if the zeros are
actually missing or if they're truly
zero and so once we have data that has
missing entries in it which is not at
all a kind of you know additive noise
model then we can't accurately compute
the distances or the additional mental
RNA matrix so how do we
how can we possibly how can we possibly
run these algorithms when the distance
matrix is incorrect it's even corrupted
so in particular you might be asking
well like how bad how bad are these
algorithms in the presence of corrupted
data you know the theoretical results
hold ok so I'm gonna take the Swiss roll
and I'm going to compute the distances
correctly this is the original data set
I compute all the distances correctly
accurately and I run I think I run ISO
map and I do the embedding I unroll the
Swiss roll and this is what it looks
like okay so this is this is ground
truth and now I'm going to take my Swiss
roll data set and I'm gonna I'm gonna
corrupt it by computing first the
distance matrix correctly and then I'm
going to decrease some of the distances
I'm going to set to zero sum of the
distances how exactly I do this week we
can discuss offline but I corrupt the
distance matrix by decreasing some of
the values and by setting some of them
to zero and I think I corrupted by I
think it basically like saying I've
corrupted 40% of the data and then I run
I so map on the corrupted distance
matrix and this is the embedding I get
which looks like utter garbage I mean it
doesn't even look like an embedding like
I'm missing points even so I so map
fails completely when I have a corrupted
distance matrix one is that is corrupted
in in this fashion and a little
foreshadowing advertisement for our
algorithm if we take the corrupted
distance matrix and we repair it as I'm
going to describe in a second we repair
it and then we run I so map the
embedding or the unrolling you know it's
not as good as
the true unrolling or the unrolling that
resulted from the true distance matrix
but it's not bad ok so this is an
advertisement for the rest of this work
so right there have been a number of
different attempts algorithms to repair
manifolds to fill in missing data and
manifolds one of them is called
nonlinear principle component analysis
and runs some autoencoder to come up
with the fill in the missing data
there's also something which now I have
forgotten what MD R u R stands for but
basically you try and learn these
mappings F and F so in the presence of
holes in your data set you try and learn
these two mappings and so you iterate
back and forth and I forgotten what this
acronym stands for so these are the in
our paper these are the a couple of the
benchmarks that we use to compare
against ok so now I'm gonna state
formally to you what I mean by manifold
repair and in particular I'm going to
state formally to you the types of
corruptions whoops the types of
corruptions that we're going to try and
address
ok so we're given a data matrix and
we're given an Oracle that tells us
whether or not the IJ entry of this data
matrix is missing and we wish to repair
as sparsely as possible by making as few
changes as possible the dissimilarity
matrix that results from computing
distances amongst points in X so that
standard dimensionality reduction
algorithms like ISO map produce good low
dimensional embeddings now this is not
the most formally precise stated problem
good is in quotes I haven't told you
exactly how
compute this dissimilarity matrix what
do you mean by standard dimensionality
reduction algorithms etc so this is
somewhat somewhat in informal but and
the results are actually going to be
somewhat informal but I think they're
interesting in in the corrupt
dissimilarity matrix know some of the
entries are missing in the data so but
then they're actually some of the
entries could be missing in the in the
in the distance matrix but the
assumption is that the entries are I
guess I should say some of the entries
in the in the distance matrix could be 0
it's not that they're missing
business who knows yes
yeah you're jumping ahead yes I gotta
explain to you when you have we have
nulls in the data matrix how do you
compute the distance all right so you
have to do something that's intelligent
which is why you need a we need an
Oracle to know ah
which one should I treat differently ok
so I will say that in the case of a
bunch of a bunch of applications you may
or may not know this matrix q you may or
may not know which entries are missing
or which entries are simply 0 so this is
somewhat of a drawback for applicability
of this work but be that as it may
okay so not these question is when you
have nulls in the data how do you what
does it mean to compute the distances
between data points and so what we're
going to do is project the data points
onto coordinates that are present in
both in order to calculate the distance
between them so here I have the rows of
this matrix are the data points and
wherever I have a star I simply in in
either data and I know either data point
I simply ignore that entry in
calculating the distance okay so I've
done a small example for the l1 distance
between amongst these three points
and l1 because it's easier to type set
without square roots I end up with a
distance matrix of this form so it's not
it's not that I have zeros necessarily
we're missing entries in the distance
matrix I have missing entries in the
data but the distances do not adhere to
a triangle do not adhere to a metric
they don't obey some of them do not obey
the triangle inequality some this
particular triangle is broken for as
bigger than three okay so what we should
note about this distance matrix is that
no distance is going to be too big
because we haven't used potentially all
of the coordinates to calculate the
distances between points so in
particular whenever we have a know we
just simply ignore it so whatever
whatever distances are in there are too
small
most likely because we've thrown away we
thrown away entries and so the right
kind of repair that one should do here
is an increase only repair okay so we're
gonna do some arithmetic yeah so okay
it's computing I'm gonna watch you
through it okay so I want to compute the
distance between this point and this
point
okay I'm too short to do this that point
in that point okay it's the l1 distance
okay so in this coordinate I have both
entries are present so I have one
because two minus one is one
okay in this coordinate they're both
missing
so I ignore that in this coordinate the
distance is 110 minus 9 is 1 so the l2
distance the l1 distance so far is 2
and then in this coordinate one of these
guys is missing so I ignore it that's
the two so the algorithm makes sense
yeah okay good and I have checked this
arithmetic several times so I think I
think okay
and I even checked oh yeah this is
really a broken triangle four is bigger
than three okay so we're going to repair
this distance matrix by running a
heuristic that we have not any of our
fancy theory approximation algorithms
FPT business we just use a heuristic to
increase these distances okay now you
can see what the right increases for
this particular example okay so I can
I'm going to tell you that there are
some things that we can prove about this
procedure in a very limited model case
and we can't prove a whole lot so what
we would like to show is that first of
all there are two parts to the algorithm
one is that one is in estimating the
distances using this algorithm that cost
us and I just walk through and then the
second part is to analyze what impact
our increase only metric repair
algorithm has on these data points on
the distances so the first part is to
say look if two points are far apart
then rarely should we bring them
together
should we decrease should this distance
estimation bring two points close
together okay and then if we do if we
are in the bad situation where we've
brought to what used to be which should
be far away points if we brought them
close together then the increase only
metric repair algorithm or heuristic
should separate them should push them
apart okay so we can prove this
statement
in model setting we cannot prove
anything that involves this part of the
algorithm and this is really only a
model so what we this is I mean this is
really simple so you know suppose I have
to I have to
Gaussian clouds that are mu1 minus mu2
apart the Centers of them are this far
apart and I've got some variance and I
knock out each coordinate of these
points that are in X and the points that
are in Y with probably sorry with
probability 1 minus P okay so each
coordinate is present with probability P
okay so I've got two Gaussian clouds and
each coordinate of each point in these
two clouds is present with probability P
otherwise I have nulls ok then this
distance estimation step says the
probability that any two points are this
close together using this estimation
procedure is upper bounded by this mess
for the sake of time and napping I will
not parse this carefully one could parse
it carefully later okay
in particular one should say you know ah
what's the probability that any two
points from these clouds are close
together how close are they are they
within Epsilon and together etc anyway
okay okay so that's it that's all that's
all we can show is in this toy fake
setting we don't tend to when we
estimate distances we don't tend to
collapse two points when they shouldn't
be
that's essentially what we say with high
probability okay
so we we can
to say anything we can't say anything
good in theory about the heuristic that
we used for the increase only metric
repair other than its fast so there are
a couple of different ways that we can
ascertain how good these algorithms are
for or how good this particular
algorithm is for repairing our manifold
distances so I'm completely giving up on
any theoretical assessment so that
leaves me with three other assessment
methods the first one is eyeball is
create some synthetic manifolds and run
iso map on them before and after
knocking out data values and check what
do the pictures look like this is awful
for a mathematician but you know I just
eyeball things okay but it's not too bad
actually so here are the embeddings
under ISO map for four different
manifolds which I have completely
forgotten what they are like in higher
dimensions other than we have formulas
and so these are the projections or the
embeddings that we get from iso map when
we have the complete data and then if we
knock out 40% of the data values or the
coordinates in the synthetic manifolds
and then run iso map i'm sorry and then
correct the distances and then run iso
map you know it's not bad i'm it's not
too bad kind of they get the first point
kind of flipped very horizontally how is
that I have no idea i I have I have I
have no idea why why is it flipped
but no it doesn't really applies to I
hope I made clear that this is very far
from a rigorous assessment of how good a
job this does the pictures look okay to
quibble about any details of them you
know their pictures what it's not bad it
suggests we should do something more
right are the eyeball is just a terrible
assessment okay so how about I go look
at a data set for for which there are
claims whether you believe it or not
from which there are claims that a low
dimensional embedding is a nice way of
being able to see clusters so you can
classify better in this low dimensional
space so in particular take M NIST and
run ISO map on the the the actual
distances and then run iso map on the
repaired distances so in particular I'm
gonna do two dimensional projections of
the first thousand images of the
following five digits from Amnesty and
I'm going to knock out 70% of the data
in M nest and yeah you know still looks
pretty good okay it looks pretty good I
could even quantify how good a job I'm
doing by trying to use this projection
to classify it with a random or chosen
something adversary
I think for these experiments randomly
so some looking out you mean that you
just removed some pics up so you just
look up the whole image oh yeah right so
it's like a 28 by 28 whatever and then I
just remove I believe at random for
these experiments I remove at random
some of the pixels and I just make them
null and then I run to compute distances
I run my algorithm that L this funny
Oracle business this too much more than
what I told you this is not the most
rigorous part of the talk okay so these
are these are the pictures okay would
you would you like to see some pictures
okay so I get we got we got we got more
quantitative we are not particularly
analytical here but we got more
quantitative and we said okay this idea
was first promoted in order to do
classification better faster well I
don't know faster in a low dimensional
space of M nest and if you take an SVM
that's trained on the low dimensional
projections with no data missing this is
sort of the the benchmark you get 94%
accuracy the goal here is not to come up
with a better classifier the goal here
is to see how good a job we can do at
repairing our distances and still
classify fairly well so here sewing away
data you can use the two dimensional
structure of M these inputs in order to
replace a missing data by the village of
it's made us yes so I didn't try a bit
Lots
lots of other people have done something
very similar so note that we are not
actually trying to fill in the pixel
values we are actually correcting the
distances but amongst these various
images so it's not that we're trying to
impute the data we're actually trying to
repair the distances amongst the
corrupted data we could there they're
certainly in the computational biology
literature there what you proposed has
been done we didn't try it here and we
didn't compare to you know that that
idea okay so right so here are some
digits that have missing values can you
tell what digits they are well you I
hope you can't do this easily you can
actually if you stare at the screen from
a certain direction and not from the
other direction shutter huh if you
squint yeah you're right okay what's
definitely true if you look at the
screen from one side okay yes very good
point yes okay so I am I have I have
knocked out you know 40 percent 50 60 70
up to 90% and then repair to my
distances and looked at how good a job
my classifier does after I've repaired
the distances and it's quite good up
until about 70 to 80 well it definitely
is terrible at 80%
but at 70 percent it's still you know
it's not bad squinting yes is it a
strategy
yeah beautiful so you do repair the
distance matrix then we just run an ISO
map we just we just run ISO map you get
a low dimensional embedding and then you
run the SVM yeah it's all off-the-shelf
stuff we didn't do any of that part okay
so here are the digits okay so um I'm
I'm going to stop here because we are
exactly on time well I'm gonna I'm gonna
conclude in words with with what it is
that we did so I define the metric
repair problem in a sparse metric is
there a problem and told you a number of
theoretical results in the setting of
what is essentially a graph algorithm
and then then I gave you an application
to manifold repair an application where
I don't have a whole lot of rigorous
results but they're interesting
interesting empirical stuff my student
and I are using these ideas to look at
metric learning and also to repair
possibly or impute missing values to
understand better the datasets that are
generated by single-cell RNA sequencing
measurements where you have lots and
lots of of zeros or missing unknown
missing values okay so that's it I'm
that is that is the end of the geometry
of your datasets okay thank you
are there questions I think it's a bit
different one of these questions and
you're throwing a lot of information by
what you're doing here because you could
even if you want to reconstruct the
metric you can ask for reconstructing a
metric by completing the adventures yeah
yes right so your your thing but going
to be doing this transformation you have
doing these distances throwing away lots
of information yes but which things
should be corrected
yes you so both algorithmically I guess
you can try to do the community actually
do the completion to the psychometric
instead of just increasing things but do
you have assistance in terms of quantify
statistically how much no no it seems um
no I mean it come so empirically no we
don't have that either I mean it seems
so so given that the input to ISO map is
a distance matrix it seems too much to
do things further upstream it seems like
I mean just in but I don't have any way
of quantifying any of that or making
that statistically rigorous but somehow
it seemed the like it seemed like it
seemed like it might be the wrong thing
to do because the input was actually the
distance matrix not you know you have
information with what's corrupted in the
crossfire
yeah so no the answer is no questions
example question okay about a generative
model like about like random
perturbations like where like random you
know arrays or something is it then
possible you can get some smooth like
sonic communication oh I don't know we
we we don't have any sort of we don't
have any theoretical analysis of if you
have random random Knockouts we do have
empirical we have a whole bunch of
experiments on sort of random datasets
random input with random knockouts and a
heuristic for increase only metric
repair I have all you know I generate
random points and Rd and I knock out
entries at random and I compute you know
various LP distances then you know so I
have experiments but I don't have
anything we haven't done any theoretical
analysis yet yes three metrics ah that
is an excellent question
yes so in particular you might ask - so
that is a great question so all of this
work says I'm just going to correct -
some metric I don't know a whole lot
about what kind of metric I correct -
and in particular I don't have a way I
haven't told you yet about correcting -
anything other than a general metric so
you can we have actually started to look
at algorithms for correcting two
particular kinds of metrics so in
particular I want to correct - a
hyperbolic metric or I want - I wanna
correct to a tree metric I want to
correct to an ultra metric so that is
what Rishi is doing right now yeah
that's a great question
all right let's take speakers okay
[Applause]